[MUSIC PLAYING]
NAHEED VORA: Hi, folks.
My name is Naheed, and
I'm a product manager
in Android Connectivity.
RYAN HAMILTON: And I'm
Ryan Hamilton, an engineer
on the Chrome networking team.
NAHEED VORA: Awesome.
So let's start with
the XKCD slide.
How many of you how--
noticed this in past few years?
Raise of hands, where you
thought that Wi-Fi's flaky,
and you're trying to
turn off your Wi-Fi?
The challenge here is that
the only constant is change.
Connectivity keeps
changing underneath you,
and your application,
trying to understand
what's going on underneath,
is really complicated.
And for creating
a good experience,
we need to hide these
complexities from the user.
We don't want users to go and
turn off their Wi-Fi in order
to use the app.
It could be any app that you
can think of that the user is
using at a given point in time.
So who should care?
If you're building a
user facing application,
maybe your app
depends on mobility.
Maybe it's Google Maps
or something like that,
or you're building a gaming
application or communication
application.
Any time you know that
you need to react really,
really fast with
respect to what's
happening on the connectivity
is critical, then you should--
this is very, very important to
make sure that you address it
in your application.
And one thing I would add here
is that user drop off rate
when the delays are maybe 1 to
3 seconds or 3 to 10 seconds,
it might vary between
different markets.
So for instance, if you're an
emerging market like India,
you might see more
resilience to more delays,
but if you're in some
somewhere like United States,
if you go beyond three seconds,
you will lose your user.
So what I have here is a demo,
and it's a Google Assistant
demo.
What we are doing is we're
using this technology,
and we'll talk about
that a bit later.
But on the left-hand side,
we have no optimization
on the phone.
On the right-hand side,
there's an optimization,
and what we are doing is we are
doing a Google Assistant query,
and user is walking
out of the building.
The phone is connected to Wi-Fi,
and as the user walks out,
the phone loses
the connectivity.
Let's see what happens.
We'll make a query, and
what is doing a direction
to Oxford Circus.
It's in London.
And the one on the right--
you see the response came back
already, and the
left one, it's still
waiting and waiting and waiting.
The right one is like, ha,
I don't have anything to do.
I'm out.
The left one is, ah, finally.
This is a lot from
reaction time perspective,
and you want to have this
resilience in your app
that it can react really, really
fast with respect to what's
happening on the
connectivity stack.
So what it's using, and the
need-- what you need is you
need protocols that can handle
this different mobility, where
the device is moving
between the networks.
And so that's where the Cronet
and QUIC comes into play, where
it's the application
layer and the protocols
that you are using can
handle this mobility.
So I'll hand over to Ryan to
talk about Cronet and QUIC.
RYAN HAMILTON: I'll
try to do this quickly.
We've taken the network stack
that is inside of the Chrome
web browser and made it
available as a library for apps
to use, and we call it Cronet.
Chrome Network, Cronet, Cronet.
Since it comes from
Chrome, it's got
all of the reliability
and interoperability
that you'd expect.
It's already being used today
by a variety of Google Apps---
Search, YouTube, Maps-- and it's
even available on iOS as well.
Coming soon, it's
going to be an option
to pull from the Play
Store, so you won't even
need to bundle it in your app.
You can get the automatic
updates and security
and performance improvements.
Part of the coolness of Cronet
is that it comes with support
for QUIC, which is a new
transport we've implemented
in user space on top of UDP,
and it does some things that TCP
can't.
QUIC is a modern transport.
It provides some new features,
some better performance.
In particular, with QUIC
Connection Migration,
you can seamlessly
switch back and forth
between Wi-Fi and cellular.
It has a bunch of awesome
performance highlights.
We release every six weeks.
Comes with state of the art
security, and over to Naheed.
NAHEED VORA: And the best
part is that the platform
optimizations are
built in, so you
don't have to do anything every
time we do Android releases.
We'll automatically make
sure that it takes advantage
of all the latest and greatest
that Android platform has
to offer, so you build
it once and ship it.
For anymore questions, come--
we have a booth outside.
You can talk to us, and
we'll be happy to help.
Thank you.
RYAN HAMILTON: Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]